President Trump says we are in the
middle of a quote new American moment
his State of the Union address last
night touted the achievements of his
first year in office the president asked
Congress for unity and said he's willing
to reach across the aisle to make an
immigration deal that ensures the safety
of Americans my duty and the sacred duty
of every elected official in this
chamber is to defend Americans to
protect their safety their families
their communities and their right to the
American dream because Americans are
dreamers too
the president is offering a pathway to
citizenship for 1.8 million dreamers
immigrants brought to the US illegally
as children in exchange he wants money
for a border wall an end to the
immigrant visa lottery and changes to
family based immigration rules the
president also said the u.s. must be
ready to respond to threats from
countries like North Korea as part of
our defense we must modernize and
rebuild our nuclear arsenal hopefully
never having to use it but making it so
strong and so powerful that it will
deter any acts of aggression by any
other nation or anyone else White House
and senior foreign affairs correspondent
Margaret Brennan is with us Margaret
good morning good morning let's start
with North Korea he referred to it as a
cruel dictatorship and referred to its
depraved character what message is he
sending in to who he's trying to get
under Kim jong-un's skin believe it or
not US officials say of these criticisms
and focus on their human rights abuses
actually is an irritant to a regime that
otherwise seems to throw out all norms
but I thought it was also interesting to
focus so much on human rights if indeed
the message of the administration from
the Secretary of State is look Kim
jong-un should have nothing to fear
about sitting down and talking to us
because we don't want regime change he's
fine he can stay in power he just has to
agree to give up his news and focusing
so much on human rights for an
administration that rarely does so it is
an interesting cross-current there I
actually thought some of the most
interesting news on North Korea
yesterday was not what was in his speech
but the fact that his choice to
ambassador for South Korea is now saying
withdrawing his nomination yeah that was
a shock what this bloody nose policy
explained that that was shocking Victor
cha who served in the Bush
administration and has been widely known
to be the current administration's
choice to be ambassador to South Korea
still no nominee there and it's actually
been withdrawn reportedly in this op-ed
he lays out because of a strategy of the
bloody nose strategy a preemptive strike
he says he doesn't support their other
innuendo out there in Washington as well
but look at this we're in a middle of a
crisis you're about to have the Olympics
they're just trying to keep the tensions
low and we have no US ambassador running
our mission and to do it on the day of
the State of the Union is you as you
point out that's right that's shocking
Margaret thanks